bonsoir et bienvenue très heureuse de
vous retrouver dans Ça vous regarde ce
soir une philosophe engagée pour les
faits bonsoir Géraldine mulman ravie de
vous accueillir pour les faits c'est
votre dernier essai aux éditions Les
Belles Lettres car on en est là les
faits sont tellement maltraités
manipulés déformés qu'il nous faut
réapprendre à les défendre y compris
dans les pays libres c'est un essa
passionnant sur le journalisme notamment
à l'heure de la guerre des images on en
parle longuement toutes les deux tout à
l'heure notre grand débat ce soir sur la
situation humanitaire à Gaza
l'évacuation des premiers binationaux et
étrangers a commencé via le poste
frontière avec l'Égypte l'armée
israélienne continue son avancée dans
l'enclave les combats de la nuit ont été
intenses le bilan des victimes civiles
palestiniennes s'alourdit grand
décryptage dans un instant sur ce
plateau avec mes invités enfin NSA
franchi ce ce soir le billet philo de
Nathan dev vert l'œil sur le numérique
de Delphine Sabatier et puis Bourbon
Express l'histoire du jour à l'assemblée
de Stéphanie des pierre voilà pour le
menu on y va geréraline mulman ça vous
regarde ça commence
[Musique]
maintenant etons à un tournant de
l'offensive israélienne le Premier
ministre Benjamin netanahou parle ce
soir de succès impression
aux abords de la ville de Gaza tandis
que la situation humanitaire est
qualifiée de profondément inquiétante
par l'Organisation mondiale de la santé
des expert mandaté par l'ONU estime même
que je cite le peuple palestinien cour
un grave risque de génocide bonsoir
Elana siurel bonsoir merci d'être là
vous êtes député européenne renew c'est
le groupe macroniste au Parlement
européen à Bruxelles bonsoir général
Jérôme péistrandi bonsoir ravi de vous
retrouver sur ce plateau vous êtes
rédacteur en chef de la revue des
défense nationale donc voici l'excellent
numéro qui vient de paraître bonsoir
Johann DEAS bienvenue sur ce plateau
vous êtes directrice exécutive de
l'iremo l'Institut de recherche et
d'études Méditerranées MoyenOrient enfin
bonsoir Jean-Claude Samouillet bonsoir
bienvenue à vous vous êtes président
d'amnesti internationale France
Géraldine mulman il tombe à pque votre
livre parce que vous parlez de la
difficulté de s'informer et et de la
difficulté d'avoir des des sources dans
ce dans ce conflit nhésitez pas à
intervenir dans dans ce débat quand vous
le souhaitez avant de vous donner la
parole à tous on va faire le point sur
la situation à Gaza ce soir avec Stéphan
blakovski dans son chrono tout de
suite bonsoir Stéphane bonsoir Miriam
bons je me retourne je vous invite à
faire la même chose pour accueillir
Stéphane blakovski vous le disiez on va
tenter de faire un un point sur la
situation à Gaza quasiment un mois après
le début de l'offensive israélienne dans
ce cas-là rien de tel qu'une petite
carte je vous rappelle donc que
l'essentiel de l'offensive isralienne se
concentre sur le Nord euh si bien
qu'environ 1 million d'habitants du Nord
se sont déplacés vers le sud où il
vivent donc désormais dans des
conditions extrêmement précaire donc le
seul point de Gaza passage pardon entre
Gaza et le reste du monde c'est ce point
ici Rafa ce post frontière contrôlé par
les Égyptiens qui est le seul endroit
par laquel on peut soit faire rentrer de
l'aide humanitaire soit faire sortir des
gens qui cherchent à fuir le territoire
donc l'actualité du jour ça a commencé
hier regardez ça s'inscrit dans vos
journaux on a assisteré aux premières
évacuations euh hier donc il y a eu à la
fois quelques centaines d'étrangers
souvent des binationaux quelques
dizaines de blessés grav Palestiniens
donc évidemment cette première
évacuation a été saluée notamment par le
président Biden qui a dit que les
Américains avaient joué un rôle moteur
qui a remercié les Israéliens les
Égyptiens les Qataris pour leur rôle
dans les négociation et de leur côté les
Égyptiens annoncent que au total ce sont
près de 7000 étrangers qui devraient
dans les jours à venir pouvoir quit la
bande de Gaza le problème c'est que si
l'Égypte est prête à faciliter
l'évacuation des étrangers en revanche
aucune intention d'accueillir des
Palestiniens qui eux voudraient fuir les
bombardements israéliens il y a deux
raisons à ça premièrement elle redoute
que il puissent y avoir des
infiltrations de combattants du Hamas
sur son territoire ce qui risquerait de
déstabiliser le régime d'ailleurs vous
voyez on a vu dans la presse que
l'Égypte avait déplacé des des chars
pour éviter des une intrusion et la
seconde raison c'est que si des de
milliers de Palestiniens devaient fuir
la bande de Gaza pour échapper au
bombardement qui sait si Israël une fois
le conflit apaiser laisserait rentrer à
nouveau donc l'Égypte ne veut pas de
palestinien on écoute le président
al l'Égypte affirme et réitère son refus
catégorique du déplacement forcé des
Palestiniens et de leur exode vers les
territoires égyptiens du
Sinaï car cela ne représente rien de
plus qu'une liquidation définitive de la
question
palestinienne la fin du rêve d'un État
palestinien indépendant et de
l'anéantissement de la lutte du peuple
palestinien alors bien sûr si les
Israéliens ne veulent pas accueillir les
Palestiniens qui fuent les bombardements
ce qu'il faudrait au minimum c'est qu'on
puisse faire rentrer de l'aide
humanitaire à l'intérieur de Gaza pour
les aider mais cette fois-ci ce sont les
Israéliens qui s'inquiètent à l'idée que
cette aide pourrait servir au Hamas ou
dissimuler une aide pour le ramas on
peut prendre un exemple c'est celui du
carburant où là carrément Israël dit non
on ne veut pas laisser rentré de
carburant ça va servir à mener le
conflit pour le Hamas sauf que le
carburant il est utile pour tout le
monde à Gaza il est utile tous les jours
dans la vie quotidienne c'est ce que
explique Philippe Lazarini qui est le
représentant de l'ONU pour les réfugiés
palestiniens nous savons que le
carburant ici à Gaza est absolument
essentiel car sans carburant nous
n'avons pas de générateur nous n'avons
pas de commerce alimentaire qui
fonctionnent nous n'avons pas d'hôpital
qui fonctionne et vous ne pouvez pas
pomper de
l'eau donc si d'un côté on peut se
réjouir de voir l'évacuation première
partie de la population qui cherche à à
sortir de Gaza en revanche on voit bien
qu'il y a un problème de l'autre côté
pour faire rentrer l'aide humanitaire
d'ailleurs regardez même le président
Biden a lancé un appel à une pause voyez
il y a que pause entre guillemets il a
pas rajouté humanitaire mais alors
justement c'est la question si on fait
une pause c'est une pause pourquoi c'est
pour évacuer les ceux qui ont la
nationalité de pays occidentaux pour
partir ou c'est une vraie pause pour
permettre d'aider les gazaou qui sont
sous les bombes bah là il a il y a
Desbat là h je commencer avec vous Joan
DEAS merci beaucoup Stéphane les taux se
desserrent un peu un tout petit peu avec
alors faut être très prudent sur sur les
chiffres mais en tout cas on a plusieurs
centaines de personnes étrangers
binationaux parfois simple enfin
uniquement Palestiniens blessés qui
peuvent aujourd'hui sortir via le le
poste frontière de de ENF c'est c'est le
fruit d'un accord avec le Qatar Israël
Hamas Égypte et Qatar à chaque fois on
retrouve le Qatar c'est le pays qui
détient la clé aujourd'hui de de de la
question humanitaire notamment dans ce
conflit alors le Qatar c'est
traditionnellement un pays qui a
toujours servi d'intermédiaire dans les
les conflits entre Israël et le Hamas et
même les conflits aussi internes parce
que le Qatar parle au Hamas ce qui n'est
pas le cas des autres interlocuteurs
occidentaux qui considèrent le Hamas
comme une entité terroriste et donc de
facto coupent les ponts et ne peuvent
pas s'entretenir directement avec avec
le Hamas donc le Qatar joue ce rôle
d'intermédiaire qui est un rôle qui est
un rôle
très disons salué et très voilà enfin je
je sais j'essais de trouver mon mot ou
il est reconnu aujourd'hui comme étant
le mandataire enfin le médiateur dans ce
conflit même s'il est un peu jugé parti
parce qu'on sait que il a financé aussi
le RAM pendant pendant longtemps avec
avec l'accord des Israéliens qui c'est
ce que je précise ça il faut rester
prudent où est-ce que il pourrait y
avoir plusieurs milliers de personnes
évacué via via l'Égypte je pense que
pour le moment il faut rester très
prudent parce que ça concerne
principalement les bis nationaux il y a
une très petite minorité de personnes
Gazaoui qui sont qui sont sortis des
blessés mais ça concerne principalement
les binationaux et il faut rester très
prudent parce que comme ça a été
expliqué dans votre dans votre reportage
l'Égypte est très réfractaire à l'idée
de pouvoir laisser rentrer d' age de
Palestiniens sur son territoire mais
pourquoi vraiment par que ça semble
incompréhensible au vu de la situation
humanitaire aujourd'hui
l'Égypte pour deux raisons selon moi la
première raison c'est que d'un point de
vue stratégique l'Égypte n'a aucun
intérêt
à provoquer un mouvement de population
qui puisse potentiellement faire rentrer
des éléments du Hamas à l'intérieur du
Sinaï je vous rappelle que le Hamas
c'est un mouvement qui est affilié aux
Frères musulmans les Frères musulmans
sont l'ennemi juré d'alsiss terroriste
qui qui qui est une en tout cas un
mouvement islamiste qui est l'ennemi
juré de de d'alciss et donc alciss n'a
pas du tout envie de voir des éléments
du Hamas qui qui infiltrre le Sinaï la
deuxième chose c'est que euh et et et il
il l'a d'ailleurs très clairement dit on
est peut-être potentiellement face à une
seconde nagba la nagba pour
recontextualisé c'est ce qui s'est passé
ça s'appelle ça veut dire la catastrophe
c'est ce qui s'est passé en
1948 pendant la guerre entre la guerre
israelloarabe après la la déclaration
d'indépendance de l'État d'Israël
immédiatement après la crè
PAL és Combs et donc c'est considéré
comme dans la le narratif identitaire et
collectif palestinen comme une
catastrophe si on part on ne revient pas
c'est ça si on part on ne revient pas et
la situation là VO les gens craignent
qu'il y a un projet dissimulé comme un
projet qui se veut humanitaire les gens
craignent que le projet les gens c'est
c'est qui alors les observateurs du les
observateurs du conflit les juristes
internationaux les
humanitaires les juristes internationaux
sont à l'heure actuelle en train de
d'avancer des éléments qui peuvent
laisser penser que on a des propos
juridiquement qualifiable de
génocidaire par certains membres du
gouvernement israélien notamment benamin
netaniaou qui a cité la Bible pour
inciter à un massacre là vous dites
beaucoup de choses parce que dans ce
conflit on sait à quel point les mots
compent et sont très très important
Ilana sicurel déjà sur les
évacuations le Maroc qui est pas le pays
arabe le plus hostile à Israël dit que
la communauté internationale est
inactive est-ce que vous vous avez
l'impression que les Occidentaux ne
mettent pas assez la pression sur Israël
pour épargner les civils déjà sur ce
point-là ou vous dites cette évacuation
c'est déjà ça oui alors je voudrais
quand même réagir parce que je peux pas
rester sans sans sans commenter ce qu'il
vient de dire qui m'a profondément
choquer c'est-à-dire que l'idée l'idée
d'un génocide je crois que les les
Israéliens ont été extrêmement clair de
propos génocidaire oui non mais bon
préciser mais c'est alors ce soir il y a
de de mandataires de deux experts de
l'ONU qui disent risque de génocide et
je guillemets et je les referme un
génocide on est en droit international
un génnocide et c'est ce qui fait toute
la différence si vous me le permettez je
vais commencer par là c'estàd qu'il y a
une différence à faire et nos
téléspectateurs ne comprendront rien si
on a on n'apporte pas cette précision
c'est que en droit international on fait
vraiment la différence entre un crime
une attaque qui vise délibérément les
civils il fait aucun doute que le 7
octobre on est arrivé en plus au
paroxisme de l'horreur et de la barbarie
et c'est très documenté puisqueen plus
les terroristes ont filmé ce qu'ils ont
fait donc là il y avait d'évidence une
volonté non seulement de tuer le plus de
civils possible mais en plus de leur
faire subir le pire il est évident aussi
que quand vous avez des et c'est en
train d'arriver ces heures-ci l'envoi de
de roquet dans des zones très peuplées
en Israël on cherche à tuer le plus de
civils possible donc là on est dans un
cadre extrêmement clair pour ce qui
concerne l'attaque israélienne on est et
les Israéliens ont était très clair
là-dessus sur le fait que le but est
militaire le but est de démanteler le
Hamas et en cela en tant que député
européennes et et la France et l'Europe
comprennent qu'un état qui a été frappé
de la sorte et bien répondent pour
démanteler le ramas qui est une qui une
organisation terroriste qui nous menace
tous et je rappelle qu'on a 31
compatriotes qui ont été tués et neuf
autages Français qui sont
potentiellement toujours détenus donc
l'objectif ça n'est pas les civils et
nous sommes dans un contexte
extraordinairement compliqué puisque
comme vous le savez le Hamas fait un un
un usage extrêmement pervers de la
population civile qui est et je le dis
qui est d'une certaine manière a Tage du
Hamas puisque les les infrastructures
militaires sont dans des zones fortement
peuplé sous des hôpitaux et donc israël
ne veut faire évidemment le moins de
victimes possible
civéinttion l'élément d'intentionnalité
n'est pas là et je crois que la
dimension humanitaire je pense que les
Israéliens N sont pas du tout du tout
insensibles et d'ailleurs dans les
discussions qu'il a pu y avoir entre
Biden et et natanah entre le président
Macron et et et et son interlocuteur
israélien notamment le président Herzog
la dimension humanitaire était présente
mais il faut la France envoie des avions
hein des avions des portes hélicoptères
hôpitaux un plus aujourd'hui et et et
les Israéliens d'ailleurs je l'ai su
avait insisté sur la nécessité de monter
des hôpitaux pour accueillir les les les
les victimes donc je crois que c'est
très important de rappeler ça parce que
on ne peut pas parler parce qu'en plus
nous sommes quand même dans un contexte
français européen très inflammable où il
y a des des des causeurs de haine qui
soufflent sur les braises avec des et la
moindre étincelle peut être très
inflammable donc
attention qualification des faits on
parle des faits mais aussi de la
qualification juridique des fait cétait
important pour moi de dire Absolum on va
venir sur l'offensive que vous allez
nous aider à à comprendre et à analyser
mais mais les
mots crime de guerre est-ce que c'est à
ça on fait face quand des civils quand
c'est pas le but de l'armée mais sont
victime de bombardement quels sont les
mots à à employer justement bah il faut
d'abord souligner que euh il faut
revenir à aux fondamentaux ce qui s'est
passé le 7 octobre si on fait en toute
proportionnalité c'est comme si en
novembre 2015 il y avait eu 10000
français tués donc on est dans quelque
chose qui est extra ordinaire ce qui
n'est d'ailleurs qui n'est jamais arrivé
dans l'histoire d'Israël depuis 1948
avec autant de victimes civiles par
actes de terrorisme bon et à cela se
rajoute le fait qu'il y a environ 240
otage israéliens et binationaux qui sont
quelque part dans la bande de Gaza donc
ce qui est très compliqué sur le plan
militaire c'est qu'il n'y a pas de bonne
solution d'abord premièrement le
Hamas dire et ça souvent il y a beaucoup
de confusion dans les plateau quand on
parle des militaires du Hamas je suis
désolé les euh les membres du Hamas ne
sont pas des militaires ils n'ont pas
droit par exemple au statut de
prisonniers de guerre ils sont des
militants d'une
organisation que certains états qualifi
de terroristes comme la France bon donc
la difficulté c'est qu'effectivement
comme vous l'avez souligné c'est que
pour conduire des opération militaire
dans un espace restreint extrêmement
dense où effectivement le Hamas mélange
dire ses infrastructures à des fins
militaires ou à d'autres fins de
contrebande au milieu de la population C
civile c'est extrêmement difficile
effectivement c'est plus simple d'aller
bombarder un aérodrome militaire en
Syrie c'est sûr que là il y a pas de
donc pour vous ça ce ne sont pas des
crimes alors ce sont des victimes
collatérales d'un gu mené contre un
mouvement terroriste quand par exemple
il y a le bombardement de de d'un camp
de réfugié dans lequel en dessous il y a
effectivement des installations du Hamas
bah oui ça fait des victimes
collatérales alors maintenant est-ce
qu'il faudra dire là aussi travailler
sur l'intentionnalité c'est-à-dire les
cibles qui ont été visées étaient-elles
dire clairement identifié est-ce que on
minimise au maximum les risques
collatéraux bon ça ça va être très
compliqué d'autant plus que il faut
également souligner qu'il n'y a pas il y
a très peu d'observateurs
impartiaux dire dans la bande de gazard
et donc ça sera notamment par exemple
sur le bilan humain bon fourni par le
Hamas qui est un bilan qui est fourni
par le Hamas HM ça veut dire quoi ça
veut dire quoi divisé par combien je ne
sais pas s'il faut mais en tout état de
cause on ne peut pas le considérer comme
étant euh un bilan officiel qui a été
validé par exemple comme le fait et on
le redit a aucun journaliste
international dans la bande de Gaza
aujourd'hui Jean-Claude samouet on va
voir un reportage grâce aux équipes de
la FP puisque lafp est la seule agence
sur place dans dans un instant le laamas
prend en otage les populations
palestiniennes selon vous moi je vis
revenir un petit peu sur sur ce qui a
été dit jusqu'près présent et présenter
la position d'amnestie internationale
les attaques du Hamas le 7 octobre
exécuter des civils mutiler des civils
les prendre en otage sont des crimes de
guerre au regard du droit international
parce que les deux belligérants que ça
soit une armée régulière ou que ça soit
un groupe armé ils doivent répondre ils
sont soumis au droit international
humanitaire les Convention de Genève et
ce qu'on appelle le droit de la guerre
en fait
doncam que nous condamnons mais sans la
moindre réserve les atrocités qui ont
été commises par le Hamas le 7 octobre
et le et l'envoie de roquette le
lancement de roqu donc terroriste
simplement pour qu'on soit d'accord sur
les mots et après on avance attaque
terroriste du Hamas nous nous employons
pas le terme de terroriste nous
employons le terme de groupe armée
palestinien en l'occurrence pourquoi on
nemploie pas le terme de terroriste
parce qu'il n'est pas reconnu au droit
international et un jour si on veut que
la justice passe il faut qu'on qualifie
les choses précisément et nous nous les
qualifions précisément groupe
palestinien armés coupable de crime de
guerre c'est comme ça qu'on arrivera à
rendre justice aux victimes et au Pr
c'est reconnu quand même par l'Union
européenne par les États
la notion de terrorisme dépend de chaque
état de chaque groupement d'État donc
soyons précis basonsous sur mman il faut
quand même intéressant parce qu'on a des
faits on s'est acharné sur des corps
avec un
commandement de mutiler ça s'appelle
comment
alors un crime de guerre ça s'appelle un
crime de guerre et au niveau du droit
international c'est extrmement
grave il y a quelque chose d'un folie là
depuis qui qui d'ailleurs antérieur aux
événements actuels on narrive plus à
sentir la gravité extrême des crimes de
guerre qui est une notion effectivement
dans laquelle il y a des viols bon et il
y a une montée en puissance que tous les
sociologues et juristes notent par
exemple du terme de génocide je je je
rappelle que quelques jours après
l'attaque des des Russes sur
inadmissible sur l'Ukraine où il y a des
cripes de guerre documentés avec des
viols notamment de femmes c'est vraiment
des crimes de guerre certains je pense
notamment à l'historien Timothy snyider
a tout de suite parlé de génocide et
beaucoup d'Ukrainiens on parle de
génocide le fait que il y ait parfois
même une intention génocidaire ne suffit
pas à qualifier enfin employer tout de
suite le plus énorme des mots du droit
de la guerre ou du droit international
ou du droit disons si j'ose dire des
violences qui est le mot de génocide
donc personnellement je je pense qu'il y
a un autre mot à part crime de guerre
qui dit mieux les choses et qui est
celui des des sociologues et des
polyitologue je pense en particulier à
Jacques séelin c'est le mot de massacre
le mot de massacre suffit et je pense
qu' qu'il y a eu le 7 7 octobre tout
tous les critères d'un massacre
c'est-à-dire une attaque d'une cruauté
extrême contre des populations civiles
israélienne avec une visée indéniable
contenu de la charte du Hamas à l' Gard
des Juifs et pas seulement des
Israéliens et maintenant comme il est
très difficile de savoir ce qui se passe
exactement dans la bord de
Gaza moi je fais partie des gens qui
pensent qu'il n'est pas à exclure qu'il
y ait des crimes de
guerre avance justement s'il vous plaît
non non pas tout de suite parce que
justement jeis on avance avec l'un des
des des protagonistes on va s'attarder
sur l'offensive militaire en cours
bonsoir colonel Olivier rafovitz merci
beaucoup d'avoir patienté depuis telavis
vous êtes avec nous merci d'être là vous
êtes porte-parole de tsal tsal qui a
continué sa percée dans dans Gaza City
avec avec des des avancées importantes
des combats ultra violents d'homme à
homme manifestement des succès selon le
Premier ministre précisez-nous les
choses est-ce que la ville de de Gaza
dans dans l'enclave est encerclée ce
soir bonsoir et merci de m'avoir invité
sur votre plateau euh je vois les
émotions les mots j'entends aussi ce qui
n'est pas dit derrière les mots et c'est
vrai qu'il y a une guerre dans la guerre
une guerre dans la guerre une guerre
deation une guerre des mots dans la
guerre véritable entre l'État d'Israël
et le Hamas je vrais vous dire deux mots
avant de avant de vous répondre un
l'État d'Israël a été attaqué le 7
octobre 2023 le 6 octobre on était en
paix c'était le CESS le feu si vous
voulez le 7 ça a été le massacre le plus
horrible que nous ayons connu atrocité
sans nom et depuis le Hamas a déclaré la
guerre à Israël et nous sommes donc dans
une guerre dans laquelle nous voulons
détruire une fois pour toutes le Hamas
et éliminer les assassins les les les
ceux qui ont fait ce qu'ils ont perpétré
je veux pas maintenantors ditnous où on
est la percée l'offensive militaire sur
le terrain à l'URE où nous parlons nous
sommes dans la deuxième phase de de de
cette guerre dans le sens où après plus
de 15 jours d'opération aérienne
extrêmement intense et intensive sur des
objectifs du Hamas nous avons commencé
vendredi une opération terrestre et ce
soir alorsù nous parlons il y a des
combats extrêmement durs nous avons 20
morts depuis le début des opération et
nous sommes maintenant en train
d'encercler la ville de Gaza City et je
rappelle au niveau de l'humanitaire que
nous avons depuis le début annoncé en
arabe par différents canaux à la
population Gazaoui de quitter la région
Nord pour la région sud entre autres la
région autour de ranunes qui est une
zone humanitaire avec des médicaments
avec la nourriture avec de l'eau et ceci
en fin de compte pour éviter qu'elle
soit prise dans les combats le fait est
que le Hamas lui ne veut pas
empêcher en tout cas que les Gazaoui
s'en aillent une grande partie sont
partis près d'un million mais il y en a
encore qui sont restés et qui
malheureusement sont aage du ramas et
les combats aujourd'hui s'accélèrent
mais nous sommes extrêmement prudents
dans dans notre action contre le ramas
est-ce que vous pensez que vos buts de
guerre éliminer le ramas à Gaza sont
atteignables est-ce que vous avez
détruit une partie des centaines de
tunnels dans l'enclave comment empêcher
que que le Hamas ne pas systématiquement
par les tunnels et vous
échappe d'après nos analyses il y aurait
800 km de tunnel 800 km de tunnel de
souterrain creusé à des dizaines de
mètres sous terre la grande majorité
étant dans la ville de Gaza et également
sous des institutions donc humanitaires
comme l'hôpital de Shifa d'ailleurs nous
avons présenté à la presse
internationale fondé sur des
informations et des éléments deformation
que nous avons d'ailleurs disclosé à nos
à des états amis à des agences de
sécurité allié je pense que le général
en place sur votre plateau do être au
courant de ces documents qui ont été
donc transmis à nous à nos amis il est
clair que le Hamas si vous voulez a
véritablement créé une infrastructure de
guerre je dis bien de guerre contre
Israël d'ailleurs ces tunnel et ces
souterrain qui pourrait servir de
protection à la population civile sont
interdits à la population de Gaza ils ne
peuvent pas y aller seuls les membres du
Hamas et du Jihad islamique ont le droit
d'y pénétrer et actuellement ils sont
présents avec l'arsenal militaire du
Hamas question sur les exactions euh en
6 Jordanie cette fois on a vu des des
vidéos très très choquantes avec des
colons israéliens qui maltraitent et
torturent des Palestiniens il y a eu
aussi des des soldats de Sal qui ont pu
participer à ces exactions est-ce que
vous les condamnez vous en tant que
porte-parole ce soir et qu'est-ce que
vous dites à Anthony blinken qui arrive
le secrétaire d'État américain qui
demande des mesures concrètes à Israël
pour épargner les civils palestiniens je
suis porte-parole d' sal de l'armisraël
et non pas porte-parole du gouvernement
israélien donc avec tout le respect que
j'ai pour vous je ne peux pas commenter
l'arrivée de Monsieur Anthony blinken en
Israël qui arrive donc demain vie est
importante évidemment pour ce qui est
des la problème sécuritaire en Jud
Saint-Marie en S Jordanie comme vous
dites s'il y a des choses qui sont
faites contre l'ordre contre la loi
elles sont effectivement contre
l'intérêt à la foi sécuritaire d'Israël
et en dehors de la loi et si elles sont
en dehors de la loi ell doivent être
punies effectivement il y aura sans
doute des des enquêtes dernière question
avant de de vous de vous libérer
monsieur rafovit le le journal Liot
aonot le journal israélien parle de
négociation possible entre Israël et le
ramas Israël pourrait accepter que le
ramas quitte Gaza en échange de la
libération des otages qu'est-ce que vous
en
pensez je pense qu'il a beaucoup d'intox
et beaucoup de fausses informations qui
circulent je répète et je signe le Hamas
a massacré 1400 personnes plus même et
on a kidnappé 242 dont des citoyens
français il y a encore une cinquantaine
de personne disparu et le Hamas
aujourd'hui euh invente des histoires et
invente des des des des pseudo euh je
dirais information pour entre guillemets
changer le narratif le Hamas va être
éliminé de la bande de Gaza et si vous
me permettez je vais finir peut-être par
une note à propos des mots je suis pour
libérer Gaza mais libéré Gaza du ramas
merci merci beaucoup Olivier rafovitz
porte-parole de Sal d'avoir été en
duplexe depuis telavive avec nous alors
le général nous aider à y comprendre
quelque chose à cette à cette offensive
expliquez-nous est-ce que ce but de
guerre d'éliminer Gaza on a bien entendu
le porte-parole les centaines pardon
d'éliminer le ramasse excusez-moi je je
les mots on parle des mots voilà
expliquez-nous si si c'est possible
alors en fait c'est c'est compliqué bien
entendu par la nature même du mouvement
qui est Hamas qui est à la fois un
mouvement terroriste un mouvement
politique un mouvement social donc en
fait l'objectif euh de tsal c'est
d'éliminer la je dirais la partie
militaire euh du du Hamas et notamment
le fait que
euh israël dispose de très nombreuses
informations du renseignement mais
renseignement auquel nous collaborons je
signale que le ministre des Armées
Sébastien Lecornu a dit que nous
fournissions également du renseignement
parce qu'il faut pas oublier que
derrière il y a des terroristes il y a
le Djihad islamique et que donc il y a
une forme de lutte commune donc il
s'agit d'identifier notamment les
leaders du ramas et de les éliminer les
éliminer dans la bande de Gaza donc là
ça passe par notamment beaucoup de
combats de nuit pourquoi parce que euh
le combat de nuit euh ça a l'avantage
d'être très bien équipé en instrument de
vision nocturne ainsi de suite et puis
paradoxalement c'est beaucoup plus
facile de nuit de discerner un
combattant qu'un civil parce que vous
voyez tout de suite par exemple des gens
qui se déplacent avec de l'armement de
nuit ils vont pas faire le marché voilà
donc ça c'est aussi un élément qui est
extrêmement important mais c'est
possible d'arriver à éliminer le Hamas
cette stratégie peut-elle éliminer
parvenir à son terme on a l'impression
que la violence alimente la violence je
ne sais pas une chose est sûre c'est que
en tout état de cause d'ailleurs ça
c'est très intéressant parce queon
parlait notamment du nombre de victimes
on sait exactement le nombre par exle de
de soldats de tsal qui sont tués donc le
le colonel l' évoqué 20 soldats depuis
quelques jours on ne connaît pas le
nombre de combattants éliminé ils font
partie du du chiffre donné par par le
Hamas il y a aussi la destruction de
toutes les infrastructures effectivement
dans les tunnels les fabrication les les
ateliers de fabrication des roquettes
les ateliers de stockage de munition là
c'est assez documenté ils ont
énormément de matériel dispersé des
postes de commandement et notamment le
fait que un certain nombre B ils sont
sous-sol en sous-sol et hélas sous des
infrastructures à usage civil Johan
j'aimerais j'aimerais si vous me
permettez revenir sur un argument que je
que je trouve très grave qu'on utilise
beaucoup qu'on entend beaucoup c'est
l'argument comme quoi donc le Hamas
utilise les civils comme des boucliers
humains et qui est qui est présenté
comme une sorte de circonstance
atténuante pour justifier les
bombardements israéliens c'est très très
grave parce que c'est pas une
circonstance atténuante c'est une
circonstance aggravante parce que
qu'est-ce qui se passe ça veut dire que
Israël a parfaitement connaissance d'une
information comme quoi il fait état de
la présence de civil dans une zone
définie qui sur laquelle cette va y
avoir un bombardement et malgré cette
information Israël prend la décision de
bombarder quand même c'est-à-dire
qu'Israël prend la décision consciente
avec cette information en tête de
bombarder des civils au mépris du droit
international humanitaire Ilana séurel
alors c'est pas au mépris du droit
international puisque justement
plusieurs choses d'une part quand vous
avez et là je parle en juriste quand
vous avez une infrac une une une
infrastructure militaire et qui se sert
d'un bouclier humain qui est un crime de
guerre soit dit en passant qui est assez
clair euh et bien cette ça devient une
cible militaire est-ce que vous devez
épargner et tout faire pour épargner les
civils bien évidemment parce que ça se
fait dans des règles est-ce que les
Israéliens ont fait ce qu'ils pouvaient
en prévenant 24 he à l'avance ce qui
n'était ce qui ce qui a été fait et
heureusement ça a permis à 100 million
de Gazaoui de quitter le territoire oui
est-ce que si vous étiez vous à la tête
d'un État qui vient d'avoir une attaque
de C pleur vous et que vous aviez en
face de vous une force comme le Hamas
que qui est une organisation terroriste
selon le l'Europe et et la France et qui
se sert de manière systématique puisque
son but de guerre à à au Hamas et c'est
affirmé c'est de c'est atroce mais
c'est provoquer le plus de mort civil
dans son propre camp qu'est-ce que vous
faites donc autrement
dit autrement dit je voudrais quand même
que vous que que que
la PR IR les populations rien n'est
satisfaisant chaque chaque mort civile
est une tragédie tout le monde est
d'accord là-dessus mais simplement vous
comprenez bien dans quelle situation
absolument inexricable se trouve Israël
qui ne peut pas et d'ailleurs c'est un
combat que les forces démocratiques
partagent et bien nous ne pouvons pas
rester les bras croisés devant
leattant la derrière
9000 palestin alors là vous reprenez les
9000 c'est le du Hamas faudrait non
c'est le chiffre de l'ONU c'est le
chiffre de l'office de coordination des
affaires hum bombardement indisriminés
et disproportionnés sur les population
civile madame sont des crimes de guerre
le fait de faire un blocus et d'affamer
une population de la privée d'eau de la
privée de gazoil qui est justement pour
faire ton les hôpitaux pour alimenter
les pompes à eau pour alimenter les
usines de dessellement sont des crimes
de guerre aussi alors qu'est-ce que vous
demandez au nom d'amnestie
internationaleer le feu de façon à la
mise en place de pouvoir mettre en place
des corridors humanitaires parce qu'on a
vu tout à l'heure des personnes qui au
compte goûte finalement qui quittait la
bande de Gaza mais nous ce que nous
demandons c'est que les biens de
première nécessité arrivent et en nombre
il y a eu 59 camions hier 62 aujourd'hui
mais il en faudrait 100 par jour il faut
soulager la détresse de la population
Gazaoui qui est au bord du gouffre
humanitaire faites confiance à la
communauté internationale pour faire la
pression mettre la pression on voit il
faut continuer chacun dans notre rôle la
communauté internationale l'Union
européenne les ONG il faut faire
pression pour que il y ait un cess le
feu de façon à pouvoir mettre mettre en
place des corridors humanitaires et et
laisser le temps de négocier la
libération des des des otages Jér P rit
on sait que les Américains reviennent ça
c'est pas Joe Biden mais c'est Anthony
blinken demain est-ce que les Américains
ont les moyens véritablement de peser et
comment vous le militaire que vous êtes
voyez ce conflit est-ce qu'il va durer
il y a un pays dont on n pas parlé qui
s'appelle l'Iran or l'Iran actuellement
met de l'huile sur le feu vous avez les
les rebelles outil qui tirent des des
missilees et des drones vers Israël soit
dit en passant je pense que à Riad ils
doivent être assez intéressant de voir
comment ils perçoivent cette action le
hbola a amplifié ses ses actions la la
problématique elle est là c'està-dire
que effectivement on est le risque c'est
est-ce que le hzbolah va rentrer en
guerre Hass nasrala son chef doit
s'exprimer demain pensez qu' il pourrait
ouvrir un deuxième front c'est bah en
fait la problématique là elle est à
Teran que veut Teran est-ce que Teran
veut profiter de la situation pour
aggraver la situation et surtout
empêcher la mise en œuvre des accords
d'Abraham et donc c'est la raison pour
lequelle le déploiement militaire
américain est extrêmement important je
rappelle aussi que nous sommes présents
militairement avec un groupe autour du
portehélicoptère hibie avec bien entendu
une priorité donnée à l'aide
humananitaire mais également avec des
frégates qui sont là pour acquérir du
renseignement parce que effectivement si
euh d'autres pays dont tan veulent
mettre de l'huile sur le feu bah le
dérapage sera dramatique on va s'arrêter
là on va s'arrêter là merci à vous merci
d'être venu débattre sur ce plateau vous
restez avec moi Géraldine mulman dans
une dizaine de minutes les parti prix de
nos affranchis ce soir le regard du
philosophe Nathan de vert de retour de
téaviv sur la société israélienne à
front renversé il nous dira l'œil sur le
numérique de Delphine Sabatier qui
revient sur les polémiques autour de la
reconnaissance face et puis d' Bourbon
Express ce soir de quoi nous parlez-vons
Stéphanie d'une nouvelle tentative des
insoumis d'abroger la retraite à 64 ans
ah bah bon courage on verra ça merci à
tout à l'heure les amis mais d'abord on
va plonger dans votre livre Géraldine
munman c'est une d'une certaine manière
un peu la la suite de de de ce débat
pour les faits aux éditions des belles
lettres nous invite à revenir au récit
des reporters sur le terrain le défi est
de taille tant la défiance vis-à-vis des
médias et grand regardez c'est dans les
dans l'invitation de Baptiste gargis
charartier on en parle toutes les deux
juste après si on vous invite
geréraldine mulman c'est pour votre
analyse sur l'essence des faits rien que
les faits thème central de votre dernier
ouvrage dans lequel vous rappelez leur
importance à forceor dans une période
polluée par les fake news nous sommes à
un moment historique en ce moment où où
triomphe l'idée du à chacun ses fait que
les gens voient singulièrement qu'il n'y
a pas de commun Géraldine mulman vous
êtes philosophe agrégé de sciences
politiques et professeur à l'université
Panthéon à SAS votre ouvrage le plus
marquant reste sans doute celui sur la
liberté d'expression mais dans votre
dernier livre réflexion subtile sur
l'avenir du
journalisme il faut apprendre à raconter
les faits c'est le travail des reporters
en essayant de mettre le moins de
sensiblerie singulière possible en
essayant de de de parler de raconter à
la place de n'importe qui pour que c'est
ça le le contrat entre des gens qui
racontent et des gens quiç c'est ce que
j'appelle le témoin ambassadeur votre
livre nous plonge dans un journalisme du
réel dites-vous côté pile analyse de la
sensibilité et côté face analyse de
l'impartialité
journalistique pour bien comprendre
flashback historique vous vous appuyez
entre autes sur l'affaire drefus qui
divise la société en
1894 et à cette époque l'objectivité
journalistique fait déjà débat à chacun
s'est fait une presse drefusard d'une
part et une presse antifusard d'autre
part vous évoquez ensuite la transition
d'une presse d'opinion à une presse
d'information mais un siècle plus tard
la tendance serait-elle de nouveau
inversé avec l'hégémonie des chaînes
d'info des réseaux sociaux et
l'intrusion des intelligences
artificielles à vous lire chacun aurait
ses propres faits et grandirait dans une
réalité parallèle alors y a-t-il encore
une place pour ce témoin ambassadeur et
le journalisme de terrain est-il en
danger réponseéral est en danger ça fait
déjà un moment je pense que nous avons
eu un siècle et demi de tentatives très
belles à mon avis de raconter à des gens
qui pensaient différemment des faits des
des récits donc où il y avait des
éléments factuels pour moi souvent
sensibles perçus par le corps des
reporters et et quoi qu'on les yeux et
le corps sur place ça c'est important et
on peut avoir ensuite sur ces faits des
avis extrêmement différent ce qui est
très important c'est de reconnaître les
mêmes faits pour que le conflit des
valeurs et des idées puissent avoir lieu
sur la même réalité le contrat de
confiance justement oui que j'appelle
donc en effet T qui doit préexister
entre le public et et le reporteire de
terrain il a disparu aujourd'hui il est
très fragilisé par plusieurs choses euh
les réseaux sociaux tendent à à être des
discours plus que des récits on on on
donne son opinion on fait des blagues on
commente vous savez raconter les faits
ça prend du temps ça ça interrompt une
conversation ce temps-là n'est pas celui
exactement des réseaux sociaux et puis
au bout d'un moment c'est comme dans les
conversations entre amis il y a des
faits inconfortables comme disait Max
Weber on les met de côté et on reste
avec les fait confortables alors
qu'est-ce qu'un fait je m'adresse à la
philosophe que vous êtes la définition
et comment puis-je le reconnaître il y a
deux chapitres de ce livre où j'essaie
vraiment de définir la chose en maant
l'histoire de la philosophie je crois
que la factualité puisque les
philosophes peuvent parler parfois comme
ça a toujours une dimension sensible je
je pense que vous voyez
Myriam on peut intellectualiser tout
toute la réalité autour de nous il y a
un moment cette table je la sens elle
est un peu froide elle est blanche je je
je crois que la réalité s'impose d'abord
au corps c'est c'est le c'est un choc
sur la peau voilà je je je sais qu'il y
a des philosophes qui ont voulu mettre
en doute la vérité sensible à commencé
par notre grand philosophe national
Descartes c'est extrêmement intéressant
ce qu'il fait mais je crois que
l'histoire de la philosophie a avancé et
que le caractère sensible la factualité
le fait aussi peut-être que tout n'est
pas intégralement pensable il y a des
choses qui nous arrivent à nos corps qui
qui ne sont pas euh qui ne sont pas
d'emblé de l'intellect et je crois que
la factualité il y a une dimension de ce
genre voilà vous dites l'observateur
impartial est un idéal voir une croyance
c'est ce que vous écrivez mais même
imparfaite elle est fondamentale cette
croyance alors oui parce que si le fait
est sensible la question est de savoir
si je peux faire partager je sais pas ce
soir si je rentre chez moi dire voilà il
y avait une table blanche j'ai j'ai
éprouvé cela je je raconter cette
situation euh si le sensible est
purement singulier si vous avez une
réalité sensible et moi une réalité
sensible et les gens les uns et les
autres chacun une réalité sensible il
n'y a pas de partage possible du
sensible c'est gravissime je pense
qu'aucune société ne peut se fonder ne
peut avoir un système judiciaire par
exemple mais ne peut avoir non plus un
débat public digne de ce nom s'il n'y a
pas ce Paris d'un partage du sensible
qui n'est pas un Paris si fou que cela
il y a quand même des gens qui racontent
des histoires qui ont réfléchi à
l'impartialité en essayant de prêter
leur corps comme si c'était un corps
universel à à à une réalité essayer de
ne pas trop choisir en fonction de leurs
avis donc cet échange il est fondamental
sinon on pourra plus parler alors on va
idéal bien sûr difficile mais mais si on
on y renonce avec un à chacun s'est fait
grandiloquant et très sûr de lui quelque
chose de très grave se produit dans la
société c'est un petit peu ce que vous
dénoncez le à chacun s'est fait avec la
Virtu actualisation du monde les réseaux
sociaux on narrive plus à se mettre
d'accord sur rien aujourd'hui vous
diriez ça est-ce qu'on en est là ou il
faut pas non plus se faire
peur ce que j'appelle la virtualisation
du monde est un risque je crois
sérieusement qu'il est en cours et je
crois sérieusement que sur certains
sujets sensibles les partis parfois
n'ont même plus de fait en commun j'ai
même écrit des une page sur le conflit
israël-palestinien avant même les
événements actuels puisque j'ai j'ai
fini ce livre cet été et je je suis par
exemple extrêmement troublé par une
chose dans les reporters qui il y a 15
jours sont allés par exemple à au moment
où le Hamas a commis ses exactions sont
allés non les repors sont allés en 6
Jordanie pour voir des gens parfois très
éduqués des médecins leur demander
comment ils avaient réagi à ce qui
s'était passé à ce qu'avait fait le
Hamas ils ont eu des réponses parfois
mais ça n'a pas exister cette cette
attaque est une fake news ou alors les
Israéliens ont commis des exactions
entre leur propre jeunesse pour
justifier une entrée en guerre et là
vous voyez quelque chose qui est que un
dans certains cas vraiment très
traumatique on ne parle plus de la même
réalité c'est-à-dire que la réalité de
l'autre est plongée dans un parfait déis
et je dirais que ça gu tout le monde he
suis pas en train de stigmatiser
uniquement un peuple je pense que ce
risque il existe il existe dans beaucoup
de populations ouais c'est un risque
c'est un abîme vous dites les fake news
ne sont pas dangereuses car elles nous
trompent elles sont dangereuses car
elles nous font perdre la confiance dans
les faits il y a une femme qui a une
responsabilité particulière on va voir
son son visage elle s'appelle Kellian
Conway c'est la conseillère de Donald
Trump c'est elle pourquoi c'est si
dangereux ce qu'elle a fait parce
qu'elle a inventé cette notion de fait
alternatif donc quand Trump disait il y
avait un monde enfin non les
journalistes disaient il y avait pas
grand monde au moment de l'investiture
on avait des images elle disait il y a
des faits alternatifs à ceux que nous
présente la presse américaine euh le le
covid est difficile à soigner le
président Trump nous a expliqué que si
l' javel pouvait nettoyer une table on
devait bien avoir un moyen de nettoyer
notre corps du covid il a il y a des
faits alternatifs C cette espèce d'idée
c'est elle qui l'a inventé c'était assez
génial parce que ça a laissé tout le
monde de rond de flan vous voyez et la
vérité c'est qu'il n'y a pas toujours
des faits alternatifs il y a des des
faits imaginaires il y a des faits
rationnels 2 et de 4 ah oui il y a des
faits rationnels mais vous savez les les
fait rationnels il s'impose à nous
peut-être pas corporellement mais que de
et deux phase 4 et pas 5 c'est c'est la
factualité dans ce qu'là de d'imposant
et bien la factualité sensible
contingente cert un nombre de morts dans
les kibuts dans tel Kibo dans tel autre
kibuts un nombre de civils massacrés à
Gaza et cette question au passage c'est
est difficile à trancher parce qu'on a
pas de
journalistes internationaux pouvant
évoquer cette factualité d'une manière
qui nous donne parfaitement confiance
ils peuvent pas s'exprimer non plus ceux
qui sont là-bas de manière tout à fait
mais la question des faits lorsqu'on la
prend sérieusement elle s'impose comme
deux et deux son quatre et il y a plus
assez de gens pour dire ça en ce moment
Myriam alors il y a pas mal de
responsables y compris parmi notre
profession les médias au sens large j'en
citerai deux puisés dans votre livre
Pascal pro pour symboliser la question
des des médias en continu des chaînes
d'information en continu vous dites au
fond sur cette chaîne c'est news on a
mis sur le même plan le discours et le
récit autrement dit les avis la
subjectivité l'interprétation et le
récit des faits je pense que je risque
de mettre du discours partout et de
l'opinion partout au lieu de donner un
temps énorme à la narration qui
essayie de de comment dire qui ne va pas
de soi parce qu'elle interrompt les
conversation les jugements qui elle
essaie de de parler à tout le monde
pardà les opinions je pense que ce
temps-là est diminué partout dans les
médias mais il est vrai que si news le
dit de manière incroyablement
décomplexée quoi c'estàd nous parlons
ici des faits dont personne ne parle on
laisse beaucoup au chroniqueurs le le le
le la narration même de ces fait qui en
fait est tout de suite prise dans un
point de vue l'idée que il n'y a que des
points de vue et il n'y a rien qui
s'impose pardelà les points de vue est
extrêmement assumé tout est relatif donc
é je pense que voilà je pense que ce
risque je tiens à le dire existe y
compris chez les gens qui font de
l'antisinous que le risque c'est quoi
c'est de dire ah ben nous on va faire de
l'antisinuse en faisant la même chose
mais à l'envers on aura nos faits et nos
avis militants opposés et je m'oppose à
cela je ne pense que je pense que ce
serait une
victoire ultime de la logique signuse
non il faut vraiment raconter les
histoires que tout le monde peut
recevoir dernier exemple cyil Hanouna
que vous cite c'est autre chose de la
rumeur presque de la postvérité dans son
show TPMP vous dites il incarne la
maltraitance maximale de la notion de
fait à notre époque je donne un exemple
j'ai scripté un vrai travail de scripté
vous savez on découvre plein de choses
la faire Palmade et la drogue de
l'adrénochrome l'adrénochrome qui par
tous les chroniqueurs et on voit très
bien comment Cyril an Nouna dans cette
scène du printemps dernier met de
l'huile sur le feu ce sera vrai dit-on
disent beaucoup de comploties qenon et
cetera une substance
prélevée dans par le sur le sang des
enfants qui serait donc sacrifié par
tout un tas d'élites hollywoodien
américaines Parti démocrate et pourquoi
pas chez nous aussi et paraî-il cette
substance donnerait une forme
d'immortalité bon c'est aberrant
l'adrénochromérie existe c'est une
substance qui qui qu'on construit
parfaitement de manière synthétique ça
n'a rien à voir avec le son enfant et
c'est pas si extraordinaire que ça ça
donne surtout des taquicardies enfin
donc c'est un un délire pur mais on voit
très bien comment l'animateur là laisse
monter la fait monter la sauce et et
surtout il a cette phrase
extraordinaire un un invité en parle
mais ce qu'il dit là-dessus tout le
monde en parle on en parle énormément
sur les réseau donc il semble que ça
existe et tout d'un coup on voit bien et
ça existe et au bout de de d'un quart
d'heure ça existe et ce que je trouve
terrible c'est que le journalisme
moderne s'est construit contre la Rum
MEUR en allant vérifier avec des
reporters impartiaux j'évoque une une
daily bline journaliste américaine
extraordinaire de la fin du 19e siècle
qui qui a qui a tué une rumeur et et et
ça finalement ça va mal ces idéos là
vont très mal et la rumeur se vange à
des heures de grande écoute il y a des
rumeurs terrifiantes merci infiniment
pour les faits on s'engage pour les fait
c'est très important c'est un livre vous
l'avez compris que l'on vous recommande
sur LCP aux éditions Les les belles
lettres vous allez voir ça va continuer
à vous intéresser les parties Pride nous
affranchi tout de suite on les
accueille bienvenue Delphine Sabatier de
bmart Nathan de vert philosophe et
chroniqueur dans cette émission et puis
Stéphanie des pierres avec qui on
commence Bourbon Express l'histoire du
jour à l'Assemblée c'est vous qui nous
la racontez Stéphanie bonsoir à vous
bonsoir Myriam alors je vous raconte
l'histoire d'une proposition de loi en
forme de poupé rus les insoumis obstinés
viennent de faire une nouvelle trou
ouvaille pour reparler des retraites
leur précédente initiative il y a de
semaines ayant totalement fait pchit ils
ont donc trouvé qu'au printemps dernier
il n'y avait pas une proposition de loi
liotte pour abroger la retraite à 64 ans
mais deux une deuxième plus petite comme
pour les poupées russes elle contient
deux articles au lieu de trois elle n'a
pas été jugée irrecevable et elle est
encore dans les tuyaux de l'Assemblée
les insoumis veulent donc la récupérer
tel qu'elle rajouter leur signature et
l'inscrire à l'agenda de leur niche par
aire le 30 novembre alors je vous
épargne les raisons très techniques mais
Mathilde Panau estime que contrairement
au mois de juin la première proposition
de loi Liot cette fois le camp
présidentiel ne pourra pas s'épargner un
débat dans
l'hémicycle le subterfuge qui a été
utilisé la dernière fois pour contrer le
fait que l'Assemblée nationale ne puisse
pas voter contre la retraite à 64 ans ne
peut pas fonctionner cette fois-ci donc
peut-être que Madame y brompivé va
inventer encore de nouvelles règles pour
déroger aux choses mais normalement si
vous regardez ce qui s'est passé la
dernière fois nous sommes sur une
proposition de loi jugée recevable et
qui va abroger l'ensemble du projet de
loi de financement de de la sécurité
sociale
rectificatif alors le premier auteur de
cette non pas simple le premier auteur
de ce texte d'abrogation exhumé par les
insoumis c'est Bertrand Pancher le
président du désormais célèbre groupe
lot alors il n'a pas été consulté par la
France insoumise simplement prévenue
hier par Mathilde Panou les insoumis
reprennent votre proposition de loi
qu'en pensez-vous tout groupe
parlementaire peut reprendre n'importe
quelle proposition de loi la France
insoumise le fait dont acte moi je
rappelle que nous avions été battu en
commission des finances et là la
présidente de l'Assemblée nationale
avait bloqué notre loi de façon à ce
qu'elle puisse pas être examiné en
séance donc les mêmes causes peuvent
reproduire les mêmes conséquences vous
remarquerez que l'enthousiasme de
Bertrand pencher n'est pas débordant et
que son optimisme est assez mesuré alors
la majorité même pas peur ou on tremble
au contraire alors on peut dire Miriam
que les insoumis ont réussi quand même
leur surprise les députés renaissances
ne s'attendaient pas à cette éème
tentative d'abroger la retraite à 64 ans
le camp présidentiel voudrait passer
autre chose mais ils réfléchissent quand
même du coup à une stratégie sur la
forme comme sur le fond Renaissance
estime que les insoumis se trompe qu'il
n'y a pas de différence entre la
première proposition de loi Liot de juin
dernier et la deuxè il y aura donc un
nouveau débat sur la réforme des
retraites dans l'hémicycle bientôt
écoutez on va voir mais vous savez la
Constitution n'a pas changé donc on va
rappeler à nos opposants que
un revenir sur la retraite sur la
réforme des retraites et impossible au
titre de l'article 40 ça crée une charge
donc ça n'est pas possible puis deuxième
obstacle constitutionnel très important
c'est qu'une loi ordinaire ne peut
pas supprimer un projet de loi enfin une
loi de finance autrement ce serait
négation de l'article 493 de notre
Constitution donc ça n'est pas possible
donc il y a un double obstacle
constitutionnel très fort bon bah
l'espoir fait vivre alors c'est non
c'est un peu non chez Renaissance on
imagine déjà plus ou moins le même
scénario qu'enjint en commission les
députés du camp présidentiel pourraient
réécrire cette proposition de loi la
vider de sa substance et sortir juste
avant lesémicycle le carton rouge de
l'irrecevabilité alors nouvelle passe
d'armes en perspective sauf que c'est
Jean-René casneuf qui le dit c'est un
plat réchauffé c'est vrai que la
retraite à 64 ans ne fait plus la une de
l'actualité et surtout que la réforme
est entré en vigueur au premier se merci
beaucoup Stéphanie des pierre d'un mot
ils ont raison ils sont en leur rôle les
insoumis à vouloir continuer d'abroger
ce texte j'ai pas jugé cela je je je
crois juste que une chose se dessine
c'est que l'usage du 493 est de moins en
moins accepté est parfaitement légal et
constitutionnel mais je crois que dans
notre société malgré tout quelque chose
s'est dessiné ass une résistance à à
l'usage de de cet article on enchaîne
avec vous Nathan Nathan de vous revenez
d'Israël vous avez passé 3 jours de
TelAviv au village du sud quelle image
retenez-vous alors oui bonsoir Myriam
comme je m'y attendais j'ai vu une
société traumatisée celui qui a sans
doute le mieux exprimé ce traumatisme là
c'était le président du Parlement il av
une rencontre collective avec lui qui a
dit le 7 octobre en l'espace d'une
journée nous avons vécu la Choa la Choa
en l'espace d'une journée où l'idée que
Israël a été confronté à une épreuve à
une expérience dont les Israéliens
pensaient qu'elle était révolue et plus
encore c que ces ces attaques là du 7
octobre qui étaient des pogromes en fait
le refus des pogromes était une des
raisons pour de la création de l'État
d'Israël il y a un très célèbre poème
qui a été écrit en 1903 qui a joué un
rôle central dans l'histoire du sionisme
du poète Rahim Bialik qui s'appelle dans
la ville du massacre juste après des
pogromes qui avaient eu lieu en
Bessarabie à kishinef où Bialik décrit
les horreurs qui ont été fait dans ces
po gros mais on a vraiment l'impression
en fait de voir les images que nous
connaissons du 7 octobre et oubial
critique le mythe de ce qu'il a appelé
la passivité juive ça veut dire des
poromes où les Juifs ne peuvent pas
résister et Israël a été créé notamment
pour empêcher cela et que Israël se
retrouve dans cette situation qui était
pourtant la raison d'être enfin don dont
le refus était la raison d'être de son
existence signifie et ça je l'ai
vraiment vu de A à Z dans ce déplacement
que les Israéliens en fait ont été
confrontés à l'expérience de la
possibilité de leur inexistence c'est la
survie pour de d'Israël qui est en jeu
alors quel est la PE dire un mot à la
fin à la fin on va laisser terminer
Nathan pu je vous vous donne la parole
juste après est-ce que vous avez perçu
une dimension politique de ce de ce
traumatisme du 7 octobre oui et c'est
justement ce qui m'a surpris euh je
m'attendais à voir une société
traumatisée mais j'avais pensé à deux
possibilités ou bien je m'étais dit ça
va ressembler un peu à la France d'après
le Bataclan on se souvient de l'État
d'abattement généralisé dans lequel nous
étions tous et l'abattement était
presque le seul sentiment la tonalité
fondamentale ou bien je me disais ça va
peut-être être un peu comme les
États-Unis post 11 septembre même si je
je n'étais pas là directement mais
c'est-à-dire un pays en proie à des
despulsions vengeresses exprimé par le
président Bush de l'époque alors j'ai vu
ni l'un ni l'autre ce que j'ai vu avant
tout et c'était vraiment surprenant
c'était une un sentiment d'unité
retrouvée c'est-à-dire que depuis des
années et en particulier depuis des mois
la société israélienne est en proie non
pas une guerre civile mais une situation
assez proche de ce qu'on vécu les
États-Unis sous Trump c'est-à-dire un
clivage politique absolument majeur
notamment avec cette réforme de la
justice voulue par netaniahou des
manifestation fleuve toutes les semaines
des réservistes de l'armée qui disaient
qu'ils ne voulaient plus faire leur
service donc si vous voulez un pays qui
était en standby et en division or le 7
octobre cette unité semble avoir été
retrouvée d'un coup je vous donne un
exemple mais qui est très intéressant il
y a un organisme qui s'appelait frère
d'armes qui avait été en fait à la
manœuvre de toutes les mobilisations
anti netaniaaho et notamment pour
demander au réservistes d'arrêter de
faire leur service le 7 octobre matin
cet organisme a arrêté toutes ses
activités politiques pour organiser le
soutien aux populations civile toutes
les infrastructures en fait pour pour
aider Israël à gérer cette crise autre
exemple autre image marquante dans les
rues de Tel Aviv sur les murs comme une
sorte de stratification ou de
sédimentation ation il y avait à la fois
plein d'affiches avec les slogans pro
anti netanah des slogans de division et
au-dessus mais sans les avoir enlevés il
y avait des affiches relative à cela au
au 7 octobre et à cette unité le
sentiment que j'ai eu c'est que derrière
cette unité il y avait l'idée d'une
sorte recomposition politique du pays
profonde ce que je veux dire par là
c'est que dans le cataclysme qu'a vécu
Israël moi je peux pas vous dire le
nombre d'Israéliens que j'ai rencontré
et qui m'ont dit que ce cataclysme les a
transformé j'ai vu des gens qui m'ont
dit moi j'ai toujours été de gauche je
me suis battu pour la paix avec les
Palestiniens j'ai milité 1 et une fois
et depuis le 7 octobre je n'y crois plus
je ne crois plus en cette paix et
inversement j'ai rencontré plein de gens
qui étaient des fans absolu acharnés de
N Dano qui m'ont dit j'ai l'impression
que sa politique est un mirage je m'en
rends compte et que il faut une
perspective de paix parce que sinon on
s'en sortira pas donc ce qui m'a marqué
c'est l'idée que à la fois les clivages
avaient été aboli les clivages de
division mais sans mettre la poussière
sous le tapis j'ai une phrase qu'on m'a
beaucoup dit c'était que c'était comme
une sorte de deuxème guerre
d'indépendance au sens non seulement où
la continuité d'Israël avait été menacée
mais plus profondément que c'était la
redéfinition du pays qui s'engageait
derrière même les actions militaires
contre le ramas merci beaucoup Nathan de
vert une réactioni je trouve votre très
intéressante et l'idée d'aller réfléchir
au trauma et de voir comment ça parle un
trauma ce que les gens disent est très
intéressante en même temps il faut qu'on
fasse attention aux mots c'est le
problème qu'on a évoqué tout à l'heure
et je comprends parfaitement que dans
des familles juives où il y a eu des des
histoires de pogrome puis de choix au
passage c'est pas la même chose he les
pogrom puis la choix politiquement c'est
pas tout à fait la même chose cette
mémoire soit sollicitée mais je je crois
néanmoins qu'il faut éviter ces mots
techniquement un Porom ça se passe dans
une
population sympathisante des massacreurs
avec des gouvernements qui ont été
sympathisant des massacreurs à l'égard
de population souvent assez ghettoïé et
minoritaire là ça s'est passé en Israël
la société n'était évidemment pas
sympathisant c'est une attaque et donc
je crois qu'il faut qu'on fasse vraiment
attention même si la mémoire je
comprends très bien dans les familles
soit sollicité de cette façon mais je
suis d'accord avec vous on enchaîne avec
Delfin sabbatier vous avez été
chroniqueuse souvenez-vous il c'est pas
très marrant d'arriver en dernier parce
qu'on a moins de temps bonsoir Delphine
vous voulez revenir sur ces polémiques
autour de la de la reconnaissance
faciale on se souvient après l'attentat
d'aras Laurent vquier avait demandé de
de pouvoir expérimenter ça dans sa dans
sa région ça n'est pas possible pour
l'instant non pour l'instant c'est non
et Laurent vquier le sait très bien la
loi n'autorise pas ses expérimentations
mais pour combien de temps en cor ça
c'est la question parce que la pression
monte alors déjà le président d'vern
renal nous dit que il réclame cette
reconnaissance faciale pour détecter les
individus suivis pour radicalisation
terroriste et que si on ne réagit pas le
prochain drame est écrit d'avance he
c'est ce qu'il a brandi dans dans son
interview au parisiens et puis là encore
plus récemment c'est la région sud qui a
fait une demande assez similaire alors
que sa demande pour installer la
reconnaissance faciale devant le lycée
avait été déjà retoqué en 2019 et
pourquoi c'est interdit alors parce que
comme dans toutes les démocraties on a
des gardes de fous qui protège nos
droits nos libertés et que la
reconnaissance faciale c'est pas une
technologie comme les autres c'est
vraiment un dispositif numérique qui est
hautement intrusif les politiques le
savent très bien ils savent que c'est un
sujet brûlant ils évitent d'y toucher en
général je vais juste rappeler les
différentes caméras parce que dans la
rue on est déjà habitué au à la
vidéoprotection ce sont des caméras qui
filment point et puis il y a un degré
qui est déjà très supérieur qui vient
d'être adopté dans la loi française qui
sont ces caméras algorithmiqu là pour
les Jeux Jeux Olympiques Paris 2024 et
bien on aura des caméras qui vont sonner
l'alerte si elles aperçoivent des
mouvements de foule ou des comportements
atypiques qui voudrai dire qu'il y a un
risque potentiel pour la population mais
Notter qu'il y a pas d'identification
des visages il y a pas de reconnaissance
faciale dans ce texte dans dans la loi
française he pour l'instant c'est
vraiment la ligne rouge ou l'espace
public pas de reconnaissance de est-ce
que ça peut changer mais oui on peut se
poser cette question il y a même de
fortes chances que ça arrive il y a déjà
des expérimentations aujourd'hui de
reconnaissance faciale qui sont en cours
alors les cadres sont vraiment très
restreints avec des obligations les
utilisations elles doivent être jugées
acceptabl au vu des bénéfices obtenus
des principes de nécessité de
proportionnalité mais autoriser cette
reconnaissance faciale devant un lycée
ça veut dire qu'on va analyser
l'ensemble des visages qui passent des
passants de tous les enfants dans la rue
est-ce que c'est justifié est-ce que
c'est proportionné au vu des bénéfices
dans la lutte contre le terrorisme et
bien peut-être que la réponse va changer
justement euh parce que le contexte se
tend en France le contexte social et que
cette pression sécuritaire pourrait
faire sauter ces gardes de fou contre la
surveillance biométrique et moi je dis
juste attention parce que une fois qu'on
a accepté ce type de technologie très
intrusive la marche arrière est très
difficile aussi merci merci de cet
avertissement merci beaucoup les
affranchis pas le temps de vous faire
réagir mais je suis sûre que vous en
parlerez de cette chronique en coulisse
merci Stéphanie à très bientôt les
affranchis Merci à VOUS Jadine mman pour
les faits il faut lire ce petit essai
important aux éditions Les Belles
Lettres qui tombent plus qu'àic très
belle soirée sur LCP soirée documentaire
avec Jean-Pierre gracien à demain
[Musique]